hey guys ryan right here and i'm jerry
tv spot three and four marvel's avengers
age of ultron oh [ __ ] releasing as much
footage as they can
so that way we don't really have to see
the movie
avengers i'm gonna show you the end of
the world
boom
whoa
on me first ultron's calling us out
what are you gonna do something dramatic
i hope
let's go get in the fight
the only thing living in this world will
be made
avengers age
damn dude ultron looks more scary than
ever actually yes i've seen a lot of
really dark trailers but in that trailer
i was like ultron kind of terrifying
yeah well i mean he only says a few
things but like i like the way james
spader sounds he's just so [ __ ] like
evil yeah that's like pure menace well
it's menace but not like macho menace
like be afraid of me because he just
sounds so calm and like he's just overly
com fully convinced of what he's doing
yeah well he thinks he's like helping
out the world by like destroying it
first so they can rebuild i think that's
what he's doing it looks like a lot of
destruction i love how most like alien
or like villainous robots are always
just like [ __ ] infrastructure building
smash yeah at the same time too
it's just a 30-second spot but i thought
that was like the most fun this movie's
looked
yeah this whole time i've seen a lot of
trailers and this actually looked like
the most appealing one in a lot of ways
because i thought like this looks like a
lot of fun actually yeah yeah i was like
really on board for the hardcore action
seriousness stuff i kind of forget about
like oh yeah and then [ __ ] through
avengers man yeah this is still our
favorite our favorite hero our favorite
little comic book heroes coming to life
yeah
all right just part four let's watch
that
let's watch i'm wondering like how many
story lines they're gonna have going
here
on may 1st of the summer's greatest
heroes
reassemble iron man coming through
captain america
whoa
thor
i am mighty
black widow
hey big guy
into it yeah yeah it's always nice to be
reminded i've been wanting the humor to
come back in these trailers and it's
nice to see these tv spots really
promoting that again yeah i mean because
comic book movies have gotten much more
serious over time and not that like the
comic books themselves weren't but like
it is nice as like serious and gritty as
these movies have gotten to be reminded
like oh yeah there's still a bit of
humor well the way for the drama and the
weight to work is the investment of life
that you get from like getting laughter
from these characters yeah well that's
what makes them seem real you know yeah
exactly that's what made it so intense a
lot like i remember first avengers that
was a pretty intense film loki's in the
prison and everyone's fighting with each
other and stuff that was some scary [ __ ]
but it's because there was so much fun
leading up to that too you know these
trailers are getting me excited going
like yeah the fun's still there for sure
i hope so i hope so i mean i hope these
are indicative of what the movie
actually feels like
you want it to go in someone's [ __ ]
no that's not what that means
indicative indicative does not mean that
oh it's not
no
oh
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
jerry has a playlist on this channel
reasons to jerry movie reviews that's
right and you can follow us on facebook
instagram and twitter shout outs
aiden asher i love
all
your videos
apostrophe yes
they are awesome
thank you aiden asher yeah thanks man
aiden asher kind of sounds like i used
to know a girl um an actress named
ashley edner we don't talk anymore it's
a real personal conflict that occurred
years ago i miss her
and so
your comment granted it's positive
your name alone has depressed me oh man
i'm sorry well you know just thinking
about my personal life again okay buddy
people think oh camera's on right he's
just he's all happy all the time like a
people like adam love these videos but
it's like you don't know what goes on
behind the scenes i once punched lauren
in the face
she didn't even do anything i'm not
gonna suggest what i was starting to
suggest when you said that
we had to redo the april fools prank
where i hit alyssa with my dick
so many times
because
i wanted it to feel as real as possible
when i did it
it's just a dark world we live in man
yep so rejects universe is pretty dark
yeah so aidan if you're uh if you're a
big fan thank you but just know when the
cameras aren't rolling
it's a real dark time in my
life no
no that can't be any much